what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we're gonna watch
Wednesday episode thrust today John how
are you I am super spooky and super
excited how are you that's a great
answer I like to hear it I'm doing well
myself thank you for asking ladies and
gentlemen you know what to do please go
ahead and leave a like it makes you feel
better and it makes us feel better so
please go ahead and do it also subscribe
and click the notification Bell to get
notified when our next reaction for
Wednesday is up here on the show now and
as always full-length Reaction watch
alongs where you sync it with your own
copy of Wednesday you can find over at
our patreon page for super sexy rejects
we cover plenty of stuff exclusively
over there as well but what I really
wanted to mention today is that the real
rejects have recently partnered up with
a channel called geek that is g-i-q-u-e
and John and I we both know the owner of
this channel so it was something that we
were very much excited to be partnering
up with and essentially what geek offers
is these one minute video character
origin stories and other pop culture
related content best part is it's from a
wide variety of creators I myself have a
video up there talking about Nightwing
koi genre has two videos up there
himself and it was something we were
excited to get the word out on because
not only is it a great place to get some
extra nerdy content if you yourself are
a Creator hoping to make some extra
bucks or just looking for some extra
exposure you can join the geek community
and potentially get paid to produce a
one minute short yourself it'd be great
if you guys can subscribe to them
because in a platform that has a lot of
competition it's great to be a part of a
platform that encourages Community a
communal experience and that's a major
part of why we agreed to be working with
them anyway guys let's watch Wednesday
episode 3 right now
bag over my head for optimal
disorientation
wrists tie tight enough to cut off
circulation that rhymes you're in an
escape room you can take the mask off
Bianca
Dan that was fast my hopes were dashed
Against The Rock's bitter disappointment
my foe was no psychotic killer
or like a bunch of high school clowns
it's like every one of them the
nightshades are an elite Social Club
emphasis on Elite we have roof parties
campouts she makes a killer virgin
mojito you can get pretty wild yeah I
bet so Weems looks the other way as long
as nobody makes any waves someone like
Rowan we booted that loser last semester
what are we going to do with her
have her join I said we invited a pledge
after the crap she pulled in the Poke up
there's no way in hell the crap she
pulled she won there are no rules in the
pokeup let me save you the trouble I'm
not interested in joining you're
seriously turning us down can you
believe it
I feed myself five minutes ago
[Laughter]
temperatures like you who give
kidnapping a bad name
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
so is woe included in every title must
be if I'm going to be responsible for
nevermore's demise
the question is why am I sharing this
apocalypse with a pilgrim
the pilgrim world
maybe you're stopping the Pilgrims from
rinking the apocalypse report for their
volunteer jobs at 10 A.M sharp I trust
you will all put your best face forward
of that makeup I got Pilgrim Road what'd
you get
your eyes heat whatever that is
it's weird creepy antique store
you'll love it though
Austin I caught your rooftop serenade
the other night
I volunteered you to accompany the
Jericho High School marching band at the
ceremony oh God for the last time Rowan
was expelled everyone saw him leave have
you spoken to him since I texted him a
few times but I've never heard back or
he's dead I don't know why you care so
much it's not like you knew the guy I'm
not sure why you care so little good
question he didn't seem surprised when I
showed you this last night you've seen
it before haven't you you drew it yeah a
couple days before the Harvest Festival
it was open on Rowan's desk so I just
assumed he stole it after we kicked him
out of the nightshades come on it's
suspicious man you kind of went
ballistic on me it's unbelievable
with telekinesis
these are typical Rowan and what the
hell is crack Stone doing the picture
with you you know who that is it's
Joseph crackstone it's like Jericho's
founding father it's kind of a big deal
around here yeah look oh wow he's
everywhere genocide and turkey dinners
still got something lurking in the woods
no doubt connected to that school come
on will you stop pointing fingers at
Nevermore we're just doing my job
looking out for the well-being of our
town boss before the good citizens of
Jericho elected me mayor I used to wear
that badge remember oh you probably know
more than you're letting on
what a fake ass smile
switch volunteer assignments
things sneak to peek at his assignment
but if you're not into it no oh my God
you you're the best that's making
lemonade and lemons
[Music]
I hope Netflix has an event where you
can go to Pilgrim world that's what I
want over never world
I'm mistress Arlene a real oh
not Emily Blunt original colonist
for
1625 to Jericho's first Pilgrim
settlement
how fun
this color scheme looks the most like
Adam's Family yeah the meeting house
inside is a collection of artifacts
facts related to Jericho's most beloved
beloved Joseph kraxto and Beyond is our
privy America's first gender-neutral
restroom oh
Progressive grab a uniform and a box and
make our forefathers proud are these for
muscling tourists
[Music]
[Laughter]
local artist scoop that fella up right
here on Route 22. you're telling me
someone actually goes out and collects
Road Caitlyn turns them into that Dahmer
ethical taxidermist well had the weather
rain I want us to pick you up something
I don't need to pay for that overpriced
hipster swill I'm brewing chaga you got
kombucha in the back as well take off
that beanie show us your snake hair
conditions
[Laughter]
thank you
are not one of you from Bavaria
girl outfit kind of looks good on her
check out this greedy little freak
please I
[Music]
wowie wow dude you could have aimed at
elsewhere come here
we're gonna cut your head off
howdy programs
let him go what do you want to end up in
the stocks too remember what happened
the last time we did this dance
sweep the leg Wednesday
you dumbass and here you will remain for
40 days thank you for your generous
donation to my re-election campaign
considered a token of our ongoing
cooperation
Corporation
[Laughter]
it was my shock but I don't have any
friends
what no you remind me of my brother now
follow me I need to know more about this
crack Stone so we have a meeting house
to break into give me a retainer what
why your teeth are really good not as
straight or white as in it but still
foreign
[Laughter]
bud I'm not sure what secret crack stone
is hiding
but I have a strange feeling the answers
to my future lie in the past
the Dominic West wants to bet this crack
Stone figure still alive in some way
[Music]
but that's the girl she saw it's young
Weems codex umbaram
that's Latin for Book of Shadows
Blair Witch too great
the fake no hold the fire to it or
something serious but I doubt she was an
outcast settler okay maybe it's fake
you'd make a killing on Etsy I
proclaimed the meeting house is under
repair that book's a replica you don't
say the original was stolen last month
during the two o'clock witch trial
the original Meeting House the one shown
in that painting where is it
how the hell should I know
I only moved here from Scottsdale in
April
oh how now
can I help you
walk out with it okay yes
damn get a lot of money for that do you
think squirrels and rats could ever work
out
I mean they're two totally different
species I mean totally
why not maybe mutation and evolution I
was thinking of sneaking behind the
greenhouse tonight supposed to be a blue
moon only happens once every 23 years or
something crazy
should get a killer view from there
she's so good
by the way you you know that's where a
lot of kids go to hook up right oh my
god dude
oh that's what you were doing yeah so
you want to meet up behind the
greenhouse tonight yes
or a date
yes
I can't believe he asked I love her
she's she yeah she could be a freaking
star she's so shy you want a coffee
one of the many perks of this wonderful
assignment I'm actually here for Tyler
I'll kill him you know the original
Pilgrim Meeting House the one from
the sixth look it's kind of sketchy
squatters and meth heads use up places
to crash pad my dad has to clear it out
every couple weeks what's this about the
meth
OD I gotta make it a score yeah
if I could take you this afternoon with
my shift ends at two I know my way
around the Great Outdoors
tell me you were a Girl Scout I can eat
Girl Scouts for breakfast I'm sure we're
having Uncle who went to prison for that
Easter eggs
what's blue lighting I love it yeah
Sleepy Hollow witches in there
thing
would work I think the pacing gets
better every episode I was expecting
more too
nope
use the words little one girl to address
me again and I can't guarantee your
safety
thing a hand here
[Music]
no I can't just touch something
my vision seemed to happen spontaneously
they're not you have to learn to control
them Wednesday Adams I bet this will
give us some real inside
foreign
got ideas for dinner though
[Music]
great transition
[Applause]
oh no she was burned you're a witch
Wednesday Adams
you have been judged before God what's
your what's her name good was it goody
the goody Adams something like that we
were here before you
leaving an army with the nature and the
native Folk but you have stolen a land
you have slaughtered the innocent you
have robbed us of our peaceful Spirit
are the true monster all of you
[Music]
whoa yeah
did you get him the devil has sent such
a demon
and I will send you back
Pilgrim world does not look fun
[Music]
set it away oh
guy does make a great evil pilgrim
I don't know if that's like Jenna
Ortega's younger sister or something
leave me say something he's trained us
all to the
[Music]
boom
oh then just find the others and save
our future
foreign
what a crazy Vision she's tapped into
here yeah
oh
spooky whoa there will be no Escape for
you
she looks so badass in the rain must
have been the bearded man from earlier
Tyler you uh want some coffee
[Music]
just tell me who it is
uh the footprint's getting smaller
you saw it all right bind this
misleading [ __ ]
I know what I saw I'm trying to keep an
open mind how big
I texted him again today
said maybe we could meet up over spring
break and go snowboarding like we did
last year
said he wouldn't be able to make it
you never went snowboarding last year
part of me wanted to blame his recent
weirdness I did think
it was almost like they went
snowboarding yeah
so I've lived with the cell
ular and the first thing they'll tell
you the psychic Visions can't be trusted
they only show you one part of the
picture he gathered all the outcasts in
the meeting house and burned them alive
okay he was a sadistic [ __ ]
I mean a mass murderer
cracked Stone was standing in the quad
you're creating a story in your head and
using Visions to back it up they're
telling you what you want to see are you
mansplaining my power
well actually I would warn you that
psychic ability isn't rooted in logic
it's triggered by emotions and let's be
honest the motion isn't exactly your
strong suit
so yours must be a little more reliable
actually someone has repressed as her
would have a lot of emotion it's
obviously Tyler
I don't buy a g we've built a monument
to celebrate his memory now may the
spirit of Joseph crackstone be
memorialized for
eternity
yay
[Music]
[Applause]
it's great seeing him in front of the
white church after all that with the
water
good inversion
[Music]
oh damn what's going on
[Music]
oh the revenge
the revenge
dude still asleep
[Music]
I'll come a Wednesday I would react a
little bit yeah come on
[Music]
although I'm with you oh yeah it's cool
[Music]
I love it I love it
[Music]
Let It Burn
Let It Burn
[Music]
sweet
you're already on thin ice I swear on my
late scorpion soul my hands are clean
[Music]
the family hand on the other hand
why does this town even have an Outreach
day don't you know it's real history
without casts I do
to an extent then it might be complicit
in its cover-up
those who forget history are doomed to
repeat it
well you see do
I see opportunity
maybe this is a chance to rewrite the
wrongs capital is
perdumity
Who the hell's there
why is he killing him it's a really good
burst why why why kill the guy He Knew
Too Much
such a life
wish me luck if he breaks your heart
I'll nail gun has
[Music]
is going on here
this is a classic piece of music
I see you normie one coincidence is just
a coincidence
two are a clue
three are proof
[Music]
ah so subtle oh no no no no
no
dude no no
oh
great that's why you don't get stoned in
the shower
[Music]
tragic three coincidences that I know
are connected
[Music]
yeah
enjoy that crumple that did it better is
this it
uh what's the song
I've been trying to figure it out this
whole time
I I hear this I hear the tune
Cornell and Christian enlisted a band
earlier trying to give us that one
Fleetwood Mac
is it Fleetwood Mac
no I don't know dead monster could be
anymore
huh oh damn all the normies aren't as
Normy as they appear
the truth is
there were Monsters Everywhere
oh that's morbid the monsters we suspect
are the most dangerous
[Music]
they hide in the shadows until no one is
looking
and then they strike no Christ
and I won't stop until I
[Music]
ooh
[Music]
that's a weird looking bear
but I guess that's what it has to be
[Music]
[Music]
oh he's seen that creature before
yep yeah you say that crazy
oh he's seen it he's seen it
never care for what they do
that's right man he knows he knows the
Beast
all right that's Chit Chat springboard
us would you I am really enjoying the
progression of this show I feel like I
feel like you know in the in the vague
amounts I have heard of the discourse
everybody kind of agrees that the first
episode you know needs a little
it gets smoother from the start and
that's been my experience I think that's
definitely been echoed in some of your
comments as well over this and yeah I've
really been enjoying just the descent
into and the immersion into just the
tone of the world that they've drawn you
know there's the mystery and all that
stuff and there's The Quirk and
everything but just I don't know the way
that they realize
this Duality between Nevermore and
Jericho I think has been really fun and
really nice and just a place I've over
these three episodes now I just kind of
look forward to spending time in so uh
so yeah I've been really just kind of
enjoying the the progress thus far and
if I'm not mistaken is that uh are they
I suppose this could be another mislead
but did we just essentially learn that
Xavier is in fact the Beast I think it's
a hundred percent of mislead yeah why do
you have scratches on his own neck
that's true see that that makes sense
scratching himself he probably tried to
intervene and Tyler's probably mad that
somebody who is close to Wednesday slash
and also a peer saw him maybe that's
what happened
I don't know we haven't really learned
what Tyler's deal is why he's in therapy
why he's
suffocating himself in the bathtub and
then letting out an anguish scream why
can you answer that I can't I think
something to do with the fact that maybe
he's got a monster ability sure and boom
shakalaka accidentally kill mommy and
even Sheriff Donovan Galpin was like God
damn that boy
that boy ain't right yeah he's on uh
because because isn't isn't the doctor
the therapist Valerie I thought she only
works with
I I don't remember well enough I don't
remember it does but but yeah they're
never more people she certainly does
work with never more people but I don't
know if it's an exclusive thing I don't
recall you know what just hit me that
that uh oh I hit you mother
for a minute my brain was like what do I
do uh the the woman in the Uriah Heap
shop is uh is disa from the rings of
power
yes thank God yeah God you got that
totally cool
so cool yeah just one of the highlights
of that show 10 out of 10 rings of power
yeah uh yeah yeah I think it's uh it's
it's starting to bleed a little bit
political which I like yeah I like it I
like that
I don't know much too much about Pilgrim
history
you know it's a it's a dark spot for me
I don't really know too much just a lot
of piousness and tolerance
hmm I'm speaking as a as a arm chair I
know a couple things
you know I don't I don't know I don't
know too well it's I don't know what
other than what they show here of like
sure with that kind of [ __ ] yeah I mean
you know you think of colonization and
you think of you know yeah Draconian
religious practice that led to things
like The Witch Trials but also you know
uh nasty colonization practices that
leads to stealing and burning and
pillaging and all sorts of other things
okay so I know enough
you you know enough I mean I'm sure
there were actual Pious people just
trying to set up peaceful encampments
and you know live peacefully but yes I
mean in the in the spread of you know
the the early uh settlers Across America
you know you bring in a lot of uh yeah a
lot of taking a lot of uh disease and a
lot of Destruction well I thought this
episode itself was paced at the pacing I
think consistently gets better and more
absorbing I like the escalation of her
psychic abilities because I don't agree
with this whole Xavier sentiment that he
can't trust them when I'm like she went
on a full on transportation thing this
wasn't some quick flash of images that
was uh unclear Mystique this was a full
on I have practically time traveled now
yeah to this spot in time and
it's it's interesting to learn all this
uh inclusion of Witchcraft enhancing The
Addams Family Legacy they had a line in
there the secret society about a normie
who died like some odd years ago is that
what they're saying Gomez Adams did is
that the is that the worry murder maybe
the murder yeah because they have some
mystery set up here and I'm trying to
make sure I don't lose track of
everything I did feel the
um
the because I really like the way this
episode progressed and I I really loved
the uh the how to for just for lack of a
better word just how dark it got it got
really dark by the end and I love the
moodiness of it and
it was very much like a Netflix binge
thing where you have the last episode
with this really great Cliffhanger and
then it's kind of absolved really fast
with some she knows everything already
the university knows like way too much
for any Wednesday Adams yeah she's
already not tied up and she's not
provoked whatsoever and it's just kind
of silly yeah and I I kind of wish that
sort of milked out a tiny bit more it
was one thing about that scene that I
wish was
had some kind of
maliciousness or Menace or someone or
may or at least made you believe there
was an actual threat credibly before
immediately you're putting you just back
into the environment you're already in
just with new clothes and a new Atrium
that's like one little thing that if I
was binging this I probably wouldn't
have even thought about it since since
we're reflecting on the episode that's
like one thing I wish I craved I craved
a tiny bit more of that but I really
felt the ending notes even when it's
like melancholic Montage of everything
at the end
because like the way they've introduced
this city has been so bright and
beautiful and prosperous but you know
there's a underlying Darkness that's
just percolating throughout and now we
have this ending conclusion of all kinds
of mysterious figures you got the mayor
it's clearly a greedy son of a [ __ ] got
the principle
uh Gwendolyn Christie who is fun to see
her uh chew up some scenery in a role
like this you know and then of course
with Xavier whose performance has been
growing on me every episode and uh Enid
who I think is fantastic and I like how
she represents as in a school full of
teenagers she's the one that feels the
most like a teenager yeah
the one who where the powers that she
has with in her like which were cat
werewolf something like that
um
the
those abilities
just whatever the monster that's within
her I don't mean Monster in a negative
way which is whatever the monsters
that's within her
seems to come out via metaphor
adolescence
I think she does
such an excellent job and uh the effects
are really good too the Medusa head guy
oh yeah it's great yeah the Gordon that
was great
um yeah there's a lot of really cool
stuff and the therapist is even a kind
of mysterious figure as well
yeah I have a a spooky Taxidermy in fact
I would never have a Taxidermy I think
that's uh messed up it is unless you go
out into I guess yeah depends on
how ethical is ethical taxidermy
I don't know
you know like this here is portrayed as
being ethical Taxidermy like oh this
this rat was hit by like a car or
something
I haven't we haven't I have a neighbor
who has a big buffalo head oh
yeah I don't know how I think oh that
can be but uh no I really like their
scene together uh Enid and uh and yeah
the the Gorgon dude uh I'll find his
name for you John I have an IMDb right
in front of me don't you worry John that
guy he looks like the one of the dudes
from trick or treat but I think he's too
young to be him I have no idea who it is
um can't see his name Jackson Ajax yeah
it's Ajax
um Enid and Ajax that scene they had
together I thought was really fun too
because I thought they could have you
know I mean there's a bigger fish to fry
in the scheme of the plot but I like
they that's an example of a scene where
they really just cut to the chase like I
love that Enid is just like I have been
trying to like drop these Anvil size
hints on you and uh and yeah that was
like super sweet and endearing and uh
those especially her but like the way
that they they
I think there's a good point about the
Montage at the end because as much as
this is Wednesday's show I think they
have done a nice job at making it an
ensemble and making everybody at least
interesting and intriguing so yeah to
have just that life expanding now and
it's like okay we have had Ajax as a
part of things up until now but this is
the sort of most we've gotten to know
him a little bit
um and so I like that too that with with
each episode you get to know just who's
around a little bit more you get to know
a little bit more about the surrounding
characters and two like uh Miss
Thornhill uh you know I love that
Christina region is here anyway but I
also am excited to see her part of the
mystery unfold I don't know like she is
the the the quintessential like I bet
you're not actually ignore me because
they make so much out of you being
ignore me but there are a few people
like you know the like Ricky Lindholm
and uh some other characters who are
pitched that way I feel like part by the
end almost probably like all the normies
are probably gonna be not normies and
maybe that'll be part of the point
well I think it sounds kind of degrading
Normie yeah sure
you know yeah it does it sounds a little
degrading sure
I'll stop using it I'm sorry yeah
this is this is the wokest thing Tim
Burton has made so far so I should be in
more in line with that sure sure uh I
think Tim Burton's direction is really
great and the music's really solid yes
this was this felt I want to call this
episode of filler because it's certainly
advancing the plot in every way
um but yeah but this it also is setting
up a different type of Direction I think
where the Ensemble is more fleshed out
in a way that feels really intriguing
and I like the I like the cinematography
of the pilgrim World a lot it felt very
Wednesday it felt very Adam's family
and just the designs and everything too
oh yeah put it in black and white too
it's just the just the world of it and
the b-boy I think is really interesting
to have Eugene uh to have him in here
because they call it out they're like
you remind me of your brother and he
does feel like the surrogate for Pugsley
it's just kind of strange when I'm like
got a whole show out they got yeah they
have a whole pocket character who
already exists world and I guess puglies
is doing fine at normal schools yeah
probably he's probably getting bullied
and [ __ ] yeah
um but I wonder if her connection with
Eugene
by the time she I'm assuming reunites
with her family by the end of the story
will
you should probably hug him you know oh
give that Pugsley a hug pug hug around
here a hugsley yeah I want to see more
Yoko because her name's Jacob yes
this is yeah there are there are a lot
of uh
interesting characters around who seem
to just fill things out and they're not
all white which is nice I imagine the
carrot the least white Tim Burton joint
as well
is it surely people have a lot of
problems with that actually I've
discovered in recent years this is he
just doesn't have a lot of people of
color cast in his stuff and are arguably
that's because he loves the I'm gonna
make you so pale you're essentially like
pure white look
um but you know it's like General
Ortega's 100 caucus well no and I like
that they embraced that here too like
you had her you know goody Adams among
the various
she's not yeah yeah yeah and I don't
know exactly what her ethnic background
is but you know like she's Mexican yeah
like there's assume there's a lot of
there is South American and Native
America and Native North American
crossover there and stuff like that and
so for what this is you know and and
expounding on a character Mexican and
Puerto Rican okay see yeah yeah
um and and not to say that not to
conflate them as being the same but I
like that they at least utilized that
aspect of their casting and I don't know
like I feel like I look back
and the sort of ethnic Side Of The Adams
Family is is never felt like one of the
more engaged elements and it's not like
the point here but I did like the way
that they had that flesh out the vision
the flashback the moments with the
pilgrims it made sense not only because
Wednesday and the Adams lineage are you
know strange and and sort of outside the
Norms of whatever time they exist in but
also based on something foundational
that is you know I don't know for a
story like this it makes sense how you
would have you know a traumatic you know
historical event in the family then pass
itself down you know it is interesting
that Tim Burton did Miss Peregrine's
Home for Peculiar Children which in some
ways is him sort of getting his feet wet
with a world like Nevermore sure
yeah
you know what I mean yeah and uh and and
Frank and weenie took place at a school
Dark Shadows they're all ethnic in there
all of them throw ethnic they're also
okay
all the black people
whatever and that's the other thing I
was like
and I'm not gonna make a real issue out
of this but I was sitting here going
okay like the mayor is kind of a phony
crooked guy who's helping prop up like
you know trim like you know crappy
history by what he does and you know uh
the siren girl is you know queen bee
adversary and whatnot and uh the mayor's
son is kind of a dick
he did Planet of the Apes
Michael Clark Duncan plays in April
that's true woke Tim Burton forgive me
it started during planet of the day
karaoke tagawa I'm gonna tread played
Crow I'm gonna tread very Softly on the
Apes
oh God what Apes joke nothing there's
nothing no no off-color jokes to be made
here
that I will definitely not engage with
right he doesn't do a lot with ethnic
people
not even to say that I think it's like
an intentional thing but but it's nice
to note like oh man look guys like there
there's
a very diverse cast of Wednesday nice
yeah well we got that out of the way
well guys
um
I am kid there's one thing I want to
look up sure uh
it does look like her but it might just
be like
spot on the thing is you're Undertaker
looks Latina
whereas that girl
um in the past the witch goody Adams she
looks white there's that blonde hair
just want to see
here it is because sometimes they do
that thing where they're like let's
let's get your cousin or your sister's
sibling yeah I want to just see who
plays her let's d a jeweler that's right
up there oh it's it is her
where Jennifer oh she plays her yeah oh
yeah it wasn't 100 sure because of the
height
I was yeah I mean I wonder if they did
any any like really subtle because
because I think with younger people you
know there's it's just more subtle when
they have to doctor stuff well she did
such a good job that I did I thought it
was I really was just like is that her
sister yeah
um no I mean I wasn't 100 sure like I
was I was pretty sure but not 100 sure
damn because she speaks a little
differently so convinced that it was a
white girl
[Laughter]
it's a white chick nah it's just that
blonde hair oh damn that's wild yeah
good to know yeah and and yeah and and
like the the subtle little Showcase of
range there is nice
well guys what did you think about this
episode of Wednesday I liked it quite a
bit
um I'm really really enjoying the show a
lot quite this is this is a really good
show it's a joy uh leave your thoughts
down below uh subscribe leave a like and
hey let's send this with a pig
Adelia Chamberlain I know Thanksgiving
was rough I hope your Christmas was
better and I hope 2023 treats you a lot
better absolutely in some ways I could
see you being like a Wednesday Adams you
know some type of Injustice pops up and
maybe you don't really like dealing with
people too much but you would still want
to do the right thing and solve the
problem anyway because you stand up for
what is wrong a good moral compass you
are the true peerer of heart exactly
exactly so Adelia I hope that this 2023
presents you with a lot more opportunity
and a lot more blessings because Lord
knows you freaking deserve it more than
John and you do I hope it's bad it
finally pays off so I love you dear and
I look forward to talking with you some
more and I hope that you have a
fantastic rest of the year and hit me up
anytime we'll talk
[Music]